[Music]
in baby driver news oh I did like that
movie too first when I saw it I was a a
little bit if he other lady started and
then I started getting to understand
like the nuances of it as a couple it's
supposed to be this way
yeah they created a world yeah it's
interesting I like it a lot
submitted by Morgan Grimes a 10 year old
took cops on a dangerous 200
mile-per-hour highway car chase well how
old 10 was he any good was he like
making some dope moves like driving
backwards at some point and still
getting a baby driver dude have you guys
ever accidentally just driven past a
hundred miles yeah 120 feels like 50 it
does I was doing that the other day in
the test lazy cuz it was late at night
yeah and just you know tied Leadfoot I
was going like a hundred and ten
especially if there's no other cars
around - yes there's no cage and there's
a 110 and then what I realized I was
going 110 I started feeling it and I
freaked out oh [ __ ] and I took it off
the gas but it's like you don't at a
certain point it's just silent yeah I
always had to put my car and cruise
control because I tend to it like
Leadfoot slowly just accelerate more and
more and I'm like oh [ __ ]
and then I get to go yeah so anyways
this guy this boy I mean 10-year old boy
he stole his dad's car and took off and
then he was on the freeway he was
endangering so many people's lives
[ __ ] [ __ ] there were the mom was
chasing after him behind them in her own
car oh [ __ ] I'm not sure exactly with
the dogs hanging out the window and [ __ ]
up
they don't mention like what caused it
the little sister's going like this in
the way
well I used to love doing that as a kid
do still do that job your amateur no no
it matures the wrong adjective this is
unattractive yeah but I'm gonna show you
guys
dashcam footage so this is in Ohio by
the way
I was just smelling my laundry shirt
here we go this deposit it's really bad
quality yeah looks like it's from 1990s
the gloves they drive them off the road
50 miles hit the mall mister get him off
the road into a ditch the crash he
kicked one of the troopers in the shin
gotcha for what you spit in my face and
kicked my [ __ ] [ __ ] it's a little kid
spit in my face after he nearly killed a
thousand people on the road I would try
to hurt him without anybody knowing I
was trying to hurt him go yeah I mean
it's like hey kid are you okay it'll be
like that but this is a lot of time by
you know like remember that one time we
did that article about the kid that got
handcuffed
oh yeah it's a different the difference
of mischievous kids it's like you don't
know if that handcuffed kid roughly the
same you know it's like it's it's it's
crazy what kids are capable of I was
like that kid and I got beat a lot now I
know why no really I would have stopped
if the cars came I turned it on and
drove it out of the driveway all the
time but I only went around the block or
like partly parked it or something like
that I didn't I tried stealing my mom's
car and I didn't know when you put it in
Drive or reverse that it goes on its own
because I thought you had to step on the
pedal so my mom's taking a shower so I'm
gonna steal my mom's car and then I put
it uh what did i do I think I put it in
Drive and I started going on its own and
good thing my dad stored the mattress in
the garage like this on my car all I was
car went straight into the mattress and
stopped right there I freak the [ __ ] out
so I put it in park and I went back
inside then when Mom
came out she's like that part this close
to the mattress yeah my you gotta be
careful yeah I got scared you're brave
you know what I figured it out as a
person who might be a father in the
future I'm gonna get my kid a car like
when they're like 16 or 17 right but
based on the quality of the car if
there's a stipulation for it it's like
yeah I'm gonna get you this beat-up
Honda and that'll be your first car free
of charge and whatever you get to drive
that [ __ ] wherever you want that's fine
just gotta come home at a certain time
whatever but if you want this dope ass
[ __ ] car you just have to drive me
everywhere in it you're gonna get them
like a Lambo yeah and then you you just
have to drive me everywhere in it at
least four times on this dope ass Honda
Element either get this Honda Element
or you get this lamp but which one do
you want there's a stipulation you just
have to drive neither yeah that's a lot
of trust you're gonna get your new
driver ass kid to drive you around
everywhere I'm okay with that damn I
don't have to drive just get like a
hammer or some [ __ ] my daddy needs to go
get a pack of gum you know what it is
you know yeah but they're saying that
this is the second time that the kid did
this oh they're just [ __ ] guys send
them to Bart's mom yes to go to best kid
straight [ __ ] yeah try this is it a dog
you ever smelled a [ __ ] [ __ ] love
that show because those prisoners they
say the most obscure things and [ __ ]
dude they're so creative bug you ever
smell the fresh ass before like no
nobody has like what you say that pretty
dirty
yeah like what the [ __ ] my [ __ ] hold
on you're a little bit you suck my dick
[Laughter]
it sounds so you said hold my shirt up
earlobe earlobe oh you suck my dick or
some [ __ ] what's a weird [ __ ] you know
what I mean
what's the audition process like for
that show it's like oh bring the inmates
it's a let's just run some lines real
quick they have a casting room right
like they're like pacing outside okay
okay so I'm gonna say I'm gonna [ __ ]
stamp your big belly but a stable your
dick to your hell yeah they probably get
all the guys that are on good behavior
and like non-crazy crimes or something
don't know they get them some bigger
this is one dude his name was like
dragon but he was like Mexican he was
[ __ ] he was a giant right and this
cruise this is all we talk by the way
throughout the whole thing's getting
quieter and quieter we get it but it
made it more more menacing but the guy
that guy was like I think he murdered
like in so he went one for murder murder
somebody else again got out again
whatever you murder somebody else it's
like three times is like you're [ __ ]
out but it was it was it was all bad but
it's pretty cool though you could look
that [ __ ] up on YouTube he's just super
quiet he's like dragon or something
dang well the Ohio State why the Ohio
State Highway Patrol traverses broke his
legs quote you know at that speed you
can kill somebody really easily I have a
ten-year-old myself and to look at how
well this person drove is just amazing
and everyone so lucky that there was
nothing tragic that happens so what do
you do you now take this kid and throw
him in jail or do you put him in NASCAR
school no for sure he went to juvie yes
and he had so much potential and being a
professional driver is it a waste you
would you wouldn't take him in juvie
after all that but I don't know what's
more important success or character
character for sure
yeah for sure well I don't think that's
true in America that's all these [ __ ]
successful
shadiest characters and it is sure I
think it's it's it's kind of its kind of
true in Asia though because if you don't
have good character then you're
successful all it like fall yeah that's
true damn I know man I just wonder what
it's like to break the kids leg and I
think that would be the opportunity to
do it I feel like it's easy to break a
kid's leg it's all small oh I just grab
a zit break like that I wanted to put on
the side of a curb and then just [ __ ]
elbow I feel like if you're under 18 you
could do whatever you want
wait what under 18 yeah I don't know by
15 I feel like there's certain kids out
there by 15 years you're like oh okay
you're the exception thing is that I
have a lot of friends were [ __ ]
stupid do I start at college doing
arithmetic Wow I [ __ ] you know the
entrance exam two plus two yeah the
intrinsic exam
I scored at the very [ __ ] bottom I
had to learn addition subtraction
multiplication and [ __ ] division not
even pre-algebra yeah yeah I had to
learn basic [ __ ] map well the English
I started at the like at the normal
level which is good you wanna watch
[Laughter]
abacus [ __ ] the box with the
different shapes like
I swear to god I'm a student in this
class I was in the class with a 40 year
old man that was like a reformed thug it
was like the most random it was like a
senior citizen that was just getting
back into school and it was a bunch of
dumbass like people that didn't take
school seriously the guy with the looks
and McCain all the time look that guy no
it was just a like a like a tattooed up
like older guy I wonder how they make
those dudes like relate their math to
like real life is [ __ ] it's like what's
2 plus don't give a [ __ ] full [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] 2 ounces of weed plus
2 ounces with 4 ounces oh my god Kevin
Kevin that's how keen you like how'd it
do some crazy ass math equation would
drug daily know it was through yeah
that's right it was like but this is -
it's like they wanted to go get a piece
of pie how long is it gonna take if we
drive this miles per hour at this visit
that he could calculate like that and
then like Kevin wants like five times
five you don't believe that children
shouldn't be tried I don't know I don't
think they should be tried as an adult
because one their idea of reality is so
[ __ ] skewed like theirs sometimes if
a kid believes that sound is still alive
any [ __ ] murder someone I don't think
it's the same thing as a 25 year old
murdering someone but he's a repeat
offender though but if you if you
compared 25 year old and 15 year old
we're the 25 year old is like I mean
there's like some favorite failure to
launches out there you're not 25 you
still think like you're 15 mm-hmm and
you're saying that the 25 year old be
tried as an adult in a very mature 15
year old can't be tried as an adult when
they had the same brain structure oh so
you're saying like if a 15 year old was
like it was like just a smart one yeah
yeah yeah they had like
evaluation but their evaluations suck
though because if if our prison system
is made for Reformation then everybody
should be tried relatively the same then
you know I mean that means anybody can
change at that point even adult to a
child but that's not what our prison
system is meant for or supposedly is for
Reformation but it's not yeah me because
I do believe adults can change too
because we know adult friends that have
changed for the better it just took the
right time to assess them or the right
moment in their life to change and it's
just like these kids always get it
passed so I just I just think it sucks
sometimes it's like either you should do
that same second-chance thing for an
adult if you're gonna do it for a kid
too if they haven't got it already so
mind you if they got that second chance
and they [ __ ] up again it's a
different story like they already this
kid already tried oh yeah he already
[ __ ] up multiple times you know what I
mean so it's like well kid you clearly
don't want to change so now we have to
break your [ __ ] Cheston with both I
agree with Bart's method which is why
don't we give the kid like a [ __ ]
race race car training or whatever to
cultivate that that drive for going fast
and whatever right but why don't we meet
his parents and [ __ ] them up what if the
parents are like really good parents and
somehow this cage is like I will [ __ ]
them up for being too good why it's so
[ __ ] nice you you're spoiling your
kids and you beat their ass be a little
[ __ ] meaner you know and then you go
to the kid and you get his ribs and you
break both of them and when he heals
then he knows we could do racecar
driving yeah only two ribs yeah they're
floating so you could just grab them and
break them you know here's that here's
here's the bigger thing you don't have
to have children I think people still
think not you need to have kids we have
plenty of kids out in this world you
don't need to have a [ __ ] kid if you
are not qualified as a normal human
being if you cannot take care of
yourself as a person you do not have a
right to
give birth to a child we're gonna say
own a child and then I feel like most
most people that have kids they they
don't did it they can't foresee Oh this
kid's gonna eventually be eight if
they're gonna ventually be 12 15 18 they
just did their thinking I want an infant
I wanna come in on 17 year old to me
that's all I thought about I feel and I
feel like a lot of the parents out there
I like that they only see oh I want a
little baby I want a baby but that
baby's gonna grow up and and if you're
not capable of being your own parent
then that baby's gonna growth you [ __ ]
Marie do you see the baby as 30 and then
paying for all my [ __ ] that's dope
that's a nice T you're like
[Music]
[Music]